today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block get that
here what's up you little one-arm
caterpillars he little kadai of her dogs
huh you got their sniffing for the dead
we might want to change your snout tune
and start trying to catch a whiff of
that magical music of life let's get
this hit her
[Music]
and this that's not if you listen to
that music that's slow engaging music
almost like if you're watching like a
young kind of you know maybe a young
handicapped boy get into a um like a
rowboat or something let's let's listen
again
[Music]
yeah you feel that or if you're watching
maybe a squirrel kind of um if you if
you're watching a squirrel you know that
maybe two squirrels just made love you
know and two squirrels just really just
enjoyed each other's small little just
little [ __ ] little super bodies and
now one of them is trying to you know
maybe you know still kind of talk to the
other one and be sweet and kind of
snuggle like two squirrels are just
spooning each other after a little bit
of um after a little bit of animal sex
let's hear it
[Music]
picture those squirrels
mouthfuls of a corn and no semen in
their bodies you know done out oh now
this is a different type of sound here
this sounds like maybe like a yacht like
a UH like maybe a homoerotic gentleman
setting the table for a fancy party
[Music]
you know maybe sweet Darrin is running
around is putting the silverware out
where they go
[Music]
Oh Griffin gets two spoons and that is a
little bit of enchanting music right
there and that is called new beginning
by Peter Sandburg and that is that is
classical music and that is classical
music by Peter Sandburg and that's
called new beginning and I thought about
new beginning because that's where we
are and that's something that sometimes
that's something I want in my life
sometimes is a new beginning you know I
want that original I want that nouveau
minute a you know I want that primeiro
opportunity oportunidad do you know I
want that new beginning I want to have
something I you know always want that I
want something to be like the first time
and that's what I feel like I'm always
searching for I'm always searching for
something you know I want a new
experience and that's what I'm hoping to
have in this coming year of 2019 ah
can you believe it the year is wrapped
up that thing put that thing you know
check the traps man we caught another
[ __ ] ano baby we caught another year
and I am happy to be here with you to
enjoy one another's company as we start
out in 2019 and with the hopes that we
have a new experience and that if you
are looking for a new experience in your
life that you get just that I am if you
can see me on the videotape on the
youtubes you can see I'm wearing I'm
showing my arms and I'm wearing a lean
shirt
it's like a tank top but it's doing a
little bit more it's like a tank top
that's also you know kind of trying to
show out a little and maybe be like a
dam you know a what is a woman where
sometimes and I would never wear a
woman's shirt but it's almost a I don't
know what it's called
a dam not a bra because that's just for
that's like a you know that's a real
tight shirt just for your tits but it's
more of a blouse this is almost a you
know a dark a blouse for a man because I
was just doing fitness but I'm also I
want to be brave in the new year and I'm
not afraid to show off my body tight and
a lot of you you know a lot of our
listeners know that I had you know I was
born with a rare body style you know the
doctors when I said when I was born some
of the doctors said I had the ribcage of
a large cat you know and that was
something you don't hear very much and
some of the doctors said I had the heart
of a lesbian that you know I had that
real that ticker that won't stuff you
know just be naughty and sometimes do
something deviant and you know that's
what I have you know I got that guy and
some people even say maybe I have extra
ribs 30 or 40 ribs you know when I was
young and they had a mystic in our town
and they would read your ribs you know
like a like a a mystery not a
prognosticator you know someone who
predicts the future and and this lady
could read ribs and I mean is this [ __ ]
read my [ __ ] for about 40 minutes you
know like it was a dang you know it was
like a damn Agatha Christie novel and I
think that's because I've you know
within my carriage I have so many ribs
and I had that unique body type a rare
type I'm I'm 88% torso and
well percent other parts head and
appendages I'm like I'm built like a
burnt like a gingerbread man you know
heavy on the bread and if you look at my
body that's how I am that gingerbread I
got limited you know my arms I only have
medium my arms or medium length or so if
somebody tries to hand me something I
can get it if it's not very far away
from me but if it's if it's a little
further I can't get it you know I'm that
close I'm that proximity bad boy I need
something to be close and around me I'm
that girthy soldier you know I'm that uh
it's almost like my you know I'm built
like a french bulldog
a lot of chest and shoulders and
strapping but you know but you know I
got that British attitude on that French
Bulldog with the British attitude the
Redcoats are straight up coming daddy
and I am here I'm that gingerbread bad
boy that that little oven baked treat
you know what I'm sweet in your mouth
baby and you know that baby praise God
but good to be here
and and just back in the studio here in
Los Angeles I was in New Orleans and
what did i do man we had the show at
House of Blues I'll start there and I
want to thank the people that came out
to that one and and things got a little
wild over there
and I'll cut actually um to a call right
here real quick about that experience
here we go hey feel it's not Garrett of
New Orleans man I well thank you for
calling Matthew Moore wanted to thank
you for coming down to New Orleans at
the House of Blues on Wednesday my
family and I were there the show was
great in hilarious and I just wanted to
apologize for the very loud minority
that you had to you know just tell them
shut the [ __ ] up or leave I believe is
the word you use a lot of people I think
maybe found that alarming but
tried to express that I hear that's a
lot with comedians man people want to be
the center of attention and they won't
shut the [ __ ] up and I know it bothers
you that they [ __ ] it up for
everybody else but I wanted you to know
that my family and I we had a great time
and it did not take away from the show
it was really cool
running into Dustin Poirier upstairs - I
saw that tatted up so I can meet masher
and also it was cool that your brother
posted our bright in front of us at the
show I recognize him from your video
last Christmas and now he had that duck
tail [ __ ] with him and he was right
in front of us man oh yeah my brother
does have a unique cut and he has a
little bit of a duck tail and he's a
businessman and that's very rare these
days to have that you know to be to try
and take on the likeness of a bird with
your hair and also be doing business you
know he's that corporate Warbler and and
he was there Dustin Poirier came out
that frickin you know that frisky man
right there and and and thank you so
much for the call man I'm glad your
family had fun you know it was yeah man
I got I got frustrated when they just
had some drunks and then yeah and they
had it throw some people out and part of
the issue was House of Blues does bands
they do musical teams you know teams
that do music sometime you'll see
somebody beatin on something and
somebody else's you know has a guitar
and they're you know look like they got
anxiety in their hand and somebody else
is yelling words into a pipe and that's
and that's a band and those people are
usually at House of Blues in New Orleans
but they hadn't done comedy very much so
they weren't used to the vibe and used
to the environment so we're backstage
and and they said it seems quiet out
there I said man it's not quiet out
there I said we need the crowd to be
paying attention and I said look man if
we're paying
you guys y'all gotta get the [ __ ] out
there and keep people keyed up and keep
them focused in and because there's all
the security guards and stuff we're
backstage but but everything went went
well and I and I felt like it went good
and a lot of it was just stress man you
know I've been I've been dealing with
some stress and and not managing it well
and I think some of it is I've just been
wanting you know perfection in some ways
or I mean I work real hard on on the
craft and I want people to be able to
enjoy it you know and it means a lot to
me that people can enjoy the show and so
when somebody shows up and they're just
you know just just tanked out and they
just been lip in that bottle you know
there's been just just gasps and their
liver down with just DRAM after DRAM of
you know liquor and gin and and just you
know damp falsehoods some of it's too
much at a certain point when they're
ruining the experience for others but
thanks for coming out it was a good
Louisiana experience you know I'll say
this they served us a little bit of food
backstage so I had a couple you know
some cuts of fish back there and I don't
know if I had trout or or what it was
some type of dam you know a local cut it
could have been like a local trout or a
local well I don't want to say tilapia
because I don't know what the [ __ ] that
is you know a lot of places start
peddling this tilapia and guess what I
don't know what the [ __ ] that is man but
I think it was local trout or a little
bit of ditch salmon and uh and if you
never had ditch salmon dude that's [ __ ]
I mean it's you catch it with your bare
hands and that's one thing I love about
that local hit that local cut of fish is
that when you taste it you can
that sheer joy in it you can taste the
soft palm prints of a young boy picking
that [ __ ] about the ditch but thank you
for coming out and yeah some people got
tossed out and actually they actually
hit the hotline so let me play this for
you
so um yeah my elephant friend said he
owned a house the food he was pretty
cool I went to some I'm coming back in
same time to get my house my husband art
because he said something he thought he
was like really excited to be here one
because because moved to college and he
was excited but like it was not fair and
I was - how's the food thank you
okay and so that she hit the hotline
that lady and she's probably she sounds
so hopped up on something she sounds you
know ding you know Slovakian or
something you know she sounded like she
just you know she's out there
she might be growing our cabbages or
something in her neck
you know she sound like she's really
doing you know something's going on she
sounds you know and that and that's when
you know you're when you've been
drinking too much when you sound like
you are suddenly you're bilingual no I'm
saying I never been so [ __ ] up that I
you know that I'm that I'm you know
talking in Cantonese I never been that
tanked out but she called and that
wasn't it she said it wasn't fair and
then this call hit the hotline as well
hey Theo it's your boy bread I love you
too the me and wise got kicked out of
here show kinda house blues I don't know
why I think your boy Drake the bar you
lose my trick was hating on that's cool
and look yeah I guess he ran into
somebody looks like Drake and they have
a lot I mean I'll be like this honestly
about ten percent of America looks like
Drake these days and it is
a little bit alarming more fun now one
lecture news day it's all good and
lovely but it's kind of messed up cuz
got kept for a reason I was buying
drinks at bar I'll be hitting the deck
fear reluctant Cheryl is all good and
there you go he's getting all tanked out
he's almost done you know he sounds like
he might be from Mogadishu or somewhere
and I think some of the thing is man you
just I don't like what are you gonna do
if you that tanked up but a show you
can't enjoy that my hunger and that's
the only reason if it you know if people
if it gets out of hand and otherwise man
it was a joy you know but that dude look
he calling himself writer saying you
know when people already in Louisiana
it's a wild time when you do a show in
Louisiana dude they had somebody in the
crowd yelling defense the whole time
people don't know what's going on
sumbitch was yelling wins the coin toss
you know some people does they never
been to a comedy show one lady asked
where the signups were at I said yeah I
mean doing all of it
people just it's it's an acquired
experience and you had you know and once
people go to comedy overtime they get
the hang of it but the hang of it was
not there a hundred percent in Louisiana
but a lot of people came out and did
enjoy it and and I want to say thank you
to all those people that came through a
lot of people from my hometown from
Covington Louisiana and from there in
New Orleans and and my brother came out
and he does have a rat tail he's growing
that [ __ ] out you know he's getting
loose in the back and it was just it did
feel good but for me I guess you know
I guess part of it is I work so hard you
know I like do I like it's like for me
it's like an art you know what I want to
show the art and the problem with my art
is you have to be able to hear it to get
the full color and the palette and if
they got some dude who had a couple you
know ninety or sixty four lokos and he's
he and his lady are so tanked out that
suddenly they sound Argentinian then
it's just not you know I wouldn't do
that at their at their experience so you
know I just don't know how that and they
called during the show this was right
when they were outside so but anyway
those came through the hotline and as
always you can hit the hotline it's nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three oh I got to tell you the
experience just that I had at being at
home you know it was a good time at home
you know I spent time in Baton Rouge and
you know did a little bit of fitness I
went to a mmm a place called mid-city
MMA and New Orleans and they got it
right over there they got a bunch of oak
trees and you know you'll see some
squirrels kinda and some you know a
couple of different types of rodents and
you know they'll have a little a missile
Louisiana so you have a little maybe a
rat over there eating a little you know
a cut of andouille sausage or something
like that but we went to the Dustin
Poirier two fighter and he's a Louisiana
fighter and he fights other men for
title belts and acclaim and
championships and he took me to just a
place where they were doing some
practicing they were sparring and
rolling and man I didn't realize what a
what an experience it was at this place
you know these people paired off and
next thing you know they're they're I
mean they're they're kind of they're
going against each each other
but each interaction is really just more
of an experience to help the weaker one
learn and when I say weaker I mean
whoever is weaker in whatever skill set
they are practicing so it's kind of like
you know watching this was Brazil
Brazilians is you just use it to and I
thought that was a dog when I first
heard about it I was like damn you got a
Brazilian Jujitsu how old is it but it's
a sport and it's an athletic sport and
it's really it's one of the most
Cavalier type of sports because it's two
men it's two you know and some of them
are beautiful men and some of them look
like they could be modeling you know
we're doing or definitely they got some
real legs on them some of them and I
mean damn the back strap on a couple of
these boys make me [ __ ] fire up the
grill you know make daddy wanna eat yeah
a ma but anyway what I'm saying is that
they get out there and they get in these
different predicaments and one of them
will be in front of the other one or one
of them sometimes they'll be on the
other ones kind of rear like what I'm
trying to hide uh you know like what I'm
trying to protect a little raspberry and
the other one trying to get that berry
and so it's very intricate they try to
be sneaky and sneak around each other
and it's almost like they're trying to
it's like they're it's almost like
they're it's like they're I mean they're
both looking for something but neither
one of them has it but they're kind of
pretending like the other one has it I
can't explain it really but it's like
chess they they kind of use their bodies
to you know doing leverage and it's it's
like somebody it's like two dudes
massaging each other really extremely
fast and aggressively and in unique
places and sometimes one of them can't
handle the massage and he'll tap out
it's um
but it really blew my mind on how on
just the skill sets that went into this
this Brazilian Jujitsu and I just wrote
it down right here it just blew my mind
just watching them you know there's just
so much I could see how every time you
do it you're learning at a core mental
level it just it seemed very tribal to
me it was awesome
it was a really really unique experience
and it was inspiring and I'm glad I went
in and and and saw people do this
because I've never seen this before
imagine seeing something now imagine not
seeing it that was me I'd never seen
this type of activity so to see people
you know when young men and their I mean
everybody was just sweating and just
fired up but it was never aggression
against each other it was almost a it
was just a group learning that was going
on Afeni really really it was it was
awesome man it was awesome it was a good
experience what else happened oh dude I
went to a a rich person had a party and
if you don't know what a rich person is
then you gotta make friends that have
some more money and this this man was
like a fancy you know they had a house
party and I got hired to go do stand-up
there at this rich event with me and
Bobby Lee
and re manis another comedian and we get
out there I mean this they had like
seven sofas in the dang the living room
was probably eighty by sixty feet or
something I'm surprised it wasn't a damn
volleyball net through the middle of it
thing was huge dude they had a staircase
that just went up and kid just came
right back down for [ __ ] nothing just
you know just to have a few extra they
had probably seven or eight couches in
there I thought it was a damn just a
train I was like is that a train is
there's so many of these in here
just a soft group of couching 's and it
was uh yeah just blew my mind man it was
you know they had a lot of money and
they had a very exotic meets some real
decent cuts of meat and I've had some
unique meat I've had well when I was
home dude I had damn somebody had a
little bit of hawk on them you know a
little bit of Hulk nuggets and jerky and
not much you know if you've ever eaten
hawk or not you know usually I don't
need you know I don't eat dove you know
I remember when I was young they had a
couple brothers grilling up a dove
outside of the apartment outside of the
apartments that we lived in and I'd go
out there and they would try to give me
a little cut of Dove but I don't need
piece meats you know I'm not a type of
man that eats Birds a piece doves or
partridges or anything like that but
look when somebody shows up and they got
a little bit of hawk on them you know
they got a hot little foil pouch full of
hawk me you got to have a [ __ ] nugget
or two because that [ __ ] makes you feel
you know I've had that gas station
cialis and that shit'll make your legs
sweat and that ironically will make my
feet kind of curl up like talons a
little bit you get that gas station sigh
Alice bra you get on about 600
milligrams of that [ __ ] there you can't
even write you can't even cry
you can't you just so dehydrated and
just hard you just you can't even cry
you know you look like a damn just like
a shooting stars [ __ ] you know
flirting which you get real keyed out
but when you get a chance to have a look
cut a Hulk you don't pass it up that's
some Native American style [ __ ] and a
friend of mine was like well what does
it taste like and I'll tell you what it
tastes like it tastes it tastes like a
honestly like a beef real stringy almost
like a frog leg but I'll imagine if a
frog if that frog were Captain Planet
that's what that if you get a little cut
a Hulk or you get some Hulk Nuggets
taste like and I probably only had about
a mouthful and a half and I can't even
tell you what the cost on that is but uh
but that's Louisiana you get good things
you know another thing I had that I
enjoyed while I was home coffee and
chicory and chicory I don't if you've
ever had it but it's like I mean this
[ __ ] is like it's like cocaine but it's
not a pine trees or something imagine if
you caught your coffee doing a little
bit of [ __ ] cocaine or something or
shooting up a little bit of arm smack
that's chicory
chicory make you [ __ ] don't st. it'll
give you that it'll make you [ __ ]
start looking for yourself even though
you are yourself and that's chicory and
and that's another treat to have in
Louisiana it's a common practice in New
Orleans especially you get that coffee
with chicory in it and that shit'll make
you [ __ ] you know that shit'll make
you growl out a damn pigeon breath that
shit'll make you you know want to
[ __ ] bite your cousin's neck dog and
play [ __ ] you know play uh you know
play family vampires with your cousin
that shit'll make you you know take a
sip out of your nephews neck right there
that [ __ ] his wild chicory get you keyed
up but overall it was a it was good man
it was just good it was Louisiana you
know and a lot of great people came out
to the shows man
a lot of people in my high school came
out you know we we we had a party
afterwards they get together upstairs
and I tried to be able to invite more
people up to it but it there was just
too much to do and and overall all the
responses I got were good some lady hit
me up she said I had a big booty on me
and she didn't know that until she saw
me on the stage there and that [ __ ] is
the truth you know it and I've always
had that booty you know if you look at
my if you see me don't just look up top
look at the bottom you know I've always
said and it's always been known that
I've got the ass of a Down syndrome like
a maybe a young black girl with Down
syndrome and I got them cheeks and the
crazy thing I remember when I was at
summer camp they you know sometime I
would do you know fall in the mud or I
would soil myself you know I would make
moan mud out of the inside of my body
into my pants and they would have to get
me other pants from somebody and those
pants for me usually came from they had
a young boy and he had Down syndrome and
we you know though I would always get
his extra pants so that just shows you
you know the type of body style that I
was working with when they suddenly if
they getting you you know they find some
you know some clothing for you and they
and they go to the Down syndrome section
and I'm not making fun of Down syndrome
people look
everybody has something you know but I
just remember that his name was written
on the back of his pants and when I
would sold my pants or if I would fall
in mud or something or you know somebody
would find maybe you know hoop or
something the back of my pants for some
reason then they would put his pants on
me as my replacement pants and other
children had replacement pants there and
they would put him they would put his on
me so what is that
that's called facts that is called facts
but it's that time of year where we wrap
up last year and and we get into a new
one it's a new year it's a new
opportunity and I and and and this
year's been a lot for me this year's
been a lot for me and uh and a lot of
that has been because of you guys and I
want to say thank you I want to say
thank you to the 500 people that came
out to the House of Blues in New Orleans
to the people that came out in all the
cities this year and then I've been
along for this ride man there's been a
wild year and I'm so grateful you know
I'm grateful and one of the things I'm
realizing I got to just focus more on
gratitude and being grateful for the
things that are going on because when
I'm if I can get so focused on those I
won't even have a chance to consider the
things that aren't perfect that aren't
you know it's just like there won't be
anything on the other side of the scale
if I can load up that scale of gratitude
then the weight of anything else
it doesn't really stand a chance I want
to tell you that I am coming to a couple
of places you can get tickets right now
the cities are I'm gonna label them
Omaha Irvine Addison and or Dallas Texas
Columbus Ohio
Houston Boston Atlantic City San Jose
Phoenix Kansas City and Palm Beach West
Palm Beach
and that's all occuring you can go to
Theo van comm slashed or
tio you are hey I know that I've told
you before about Marty frumm drastic
graphics he does so much work for me
over the past year and he's also changed
the way that I think about a lot of my
business and if you own a business or
are thinking about starting one then he
has a new course that is a hundred
percent absolutely for you it's easy to
understand easy to implement online
videos that break down all the
information you need to know information
that will save you massive amounts of
time money and energy building your
business in just two and a half hours
you will develop a pro level
understanding of how logo design and
brand identity can make or break your
business the best way to build your
website and online store how to outrank
your competition on Google social media
marketing and how to secure new clients
and maintain them long term the course
is created like I said by Marty O'Neil
owner of drastic graphics who has over a
decade's worth of experience working
with some of the biggest brands and
performers in the world today is the
last day you can get a 30% discount on
the entire course visit smart setup
guide.com
and use the code th EO at checkout
that's right 30% off last day is today
go to smart setup guide calm and use
code Theo and that's only if you're
listening the day that this comes out
which is December 31st of 2018 I I
cannot recommend Marty and his course
and his attention to detail I couldn't I
couldn't recommend it more um I got a
nice card some people gave me a nice
Dustin Poirier gave me a nice
certificate because we made a donation
to his the good fight foundation so that
was very kind to him and thank you to
our patreon supporters for helping us do
some neat outreach and and
and I'll say this man I had this
experience when I was at home you know I
had kind of like it was like a plateau
and I spoke about this some on on the
previous episode it was like sometimes
you go you know you go like you go to
summer camp and then you go to summer
camp again and then the third and it's
great and then the second time it's
great but then the third time you go
you're like ah I'm starting to be a
little too old for summer camp or the
games aren't as fun and you start
noticing oh now I'm thinking more about
the girls at summer camp I'm thinking
more about
oh that counselor looks cute are you
just you know and then the next year you
realize you're like oh man I'm wait I'm
too old to be just a kid at summer camp
you know the games are way too childish
for you now and and all you're thinking
about is trying to flirt with one of the
counselors and you know sometimes things
in moments and times just hit a plateau
and that was one of the things kind of
that happened to me I think this time at
home you know it was you know it's
always great to see family and to feel
that joy but I just kind of had this
experience where it was like oh wow like
you know uh you know my nieces and
nephews are getting older and they're
not you know only one of them is like a
little kid anymore else you know a small
child and it just you have this
experience it's like it's like oh it's
time for me to evolve a little
and in this just my experience and I
could have been wrong but I had this
this thing it was like oh it's time you
know the thing you know the the times
I've been having like a lot of my friend
have children now or you know or at
least are you know trying to have
children and they don't have any good
semen in them or whatever they got bad
egg 'try but there's everybody's trying
you know things are just changing you
know there's you can't stand and rage
and [ __ ] people's giving up or people's
you know died or damn who knows what
people are missing it just kind of was a
moment at home where I had a plateau and
it was like oh wow like there needs to
be you know some growing up or some
growing out or some type of change is
afoot and I sometimes I don't even know
what that is
you guys made some great calls I'm a
little tired it's been a long year and
this is the end of it you know when that
is kind of nice you know and I know the
Mayans tried it and they [ __ ] it up
and somebody else got it right you know
that other calendar and it's nice man
this is the N it's this is the end if
you're gonna have a new beginning you
can have a new experience and it's just
wait if you can make it whatever you
want this coming year whatever you want
let's take a call that came in right
here nine eight five six six four nine
five zero three is the hotline and I
want you to hit this hotline and make
this show a part of your life and
because I'm gonna continue to try to
make this show a part of my life you
know I show up here sometimes you know
when I'm overwhelmed when I'm overjoyed
when I'm struggling and when I'm sincere
there's been times this year y-you know
was I you know probably some of my more
vulnerable moments of my life and and
there's been times even this year
especially towards that you know the
second half of the year where man life's
been going so fast I've just been it's
been hard to be even be in touch with my
own feelings but but I'm not going to
give up on on this experience that we
get to have here and and we're a young
podcast you know where a young podcast
but but we're mighty and here's a call
that came in here we go oh that's that
music right there here we go
hey my name is Taylor Sinclair and a
Sinkler and I appreciate your your wild
little voice hitting these lines brother
and you sound like something very like a
good person and I want to hear more from
you let's go Daddy
I was born premature baby only born one
powerlevel ounces whoa and that is very
1 pound 1 pound 11 ounces man this dude
that's like a dang that ain't even as
big as well I got this snicker right
here and this is a slice and share
Snickers and this was given to me this
was a hand given gift in um Lexington
Kentucky and this is a Snickers candy
and this thing is 16 ounces so you were
if you said one pound one ounce let me
hear what you said again boy Jesus man
you're just a little [ __ ] stallion
rough and potatoes bigger than you bro
you're a damn side item onward I was
born premature baby I'm gone one pile
Evan out dude Oh 1 pound in 11 ounces so
that's more than this but this is one
pound of snicker
so you was maybe a little bit bigger
than this gigant you and snicker right
here and that's and that's crazy to
think about think about you was just
damn barely bigger than a large snicker
and you were living
imagine if God put life into a snicker
candy
imagine if the Lord just zapped that
[ __ ] fatty sweet right there and that
[ __ ] just walked off and grew up and
had snacks and everything in ate you
know and did life imagine if a snicker
was in school or broke its arm on the
monkey bars or you know knocked a
knocked-up a Twix in the eleventh grade
and had to drop out and work at the gas
station imagine that could that could
happen if God put the you know the life
source into a Snickers but he put it
into you and you were just barely bigger
than this candy that's [ __ ] damn
startling brah
god damn dude I feel like a damn wolf
just [ __ ] in my brain man let's hear
more guys something through the mail let
me show you pictures of the for the
little guy boys man I could only fit in
a Cabbage Patch clothes no guilt oh wow
so you was and we had a boy by us
Kenneth was his name and his parents
would put him in he was very small
something that happened to him I don't
know and he got born I mean he probably
only had about half a cup of blood in
his body you know and maybe damn six
teaspoons of plasma or something bright
you could probably I mean his legs was
damn looked like two big buffalo wings
you know breaded and his parents used to
get doll clothing for him double extra
and triple extra-large a teddy bear T
bear clothing so you'd see him with a
damn you know a little shirt on it was
say uh mr. bear on the back you know a
lot of his closest [ __ ] like that you
know or it would say get well because he
would get a lot of you know they would
get a lot of gift shops teddy bears have
little shirts
from hospitals people get that little
get somebody of a little [ __ ] polar
bear said get well on the shirt and he
would have that shirt on you see him
with that little like damn all his
shirts said get well because his parents
was getting double extra and tripled
extra and quad xl's
large uh you know plush animal clothing
clothing off of [ __ ] gift shop
animals and putting them onto that boy
so I've seen stuff like that but Hot
Diggity damn that's wild to think he was
wearing Cabbage Patch clothing Oh word
uh I think Lister to your podcast and
listeners you know comedy for a while
now I love your unique style and how you
reach out to be foreign strata health
and in any way possible on today is the
best news in my life today I just got
approved for our rehab I've been
drinking my life away for damn near
decade being piece of [ __ ] and why not
and I'm certain in today's Thursday the
27th so I'm certain going into the new
year with the right direction and the
right sleep Wow
man congratulations you know God made
you small but man you have a really big
opportunity ahead of you you know there
is an opportunity for you to have just a
new experience with life you know
imagine if all of the fears and all the
uncertainties imagine if they just just
just just left you just fell out of you
and I mean fell away so far away so
quickly that you forgot they ever even
existed I'm talking about the the
uncertainties and the self-loathing and
the the low self confidence if those
things that probably spin around in your
head a lot imagine if they disappeared
so quickly and so and I mean gone like
they stole a damn the last slice of pie
and you can so and they disappeared so
much that you couldn't even remember
that you had them these ghosts that have
been living inside of you for damn near
whatever a lot of your life imagine if
they disappeared well I'm telling you
bro from my own experience I'm not
preaching at you but I'm just saying
that through recovery and stuff that
could be a possibility so that's amazing
today I'm gonna think you go from
wearing Cabbage Patch clothes to
actually runnin mr. McGregor's garden a
different type of environment man you
can have a new experience
congratulations brother and thank you
for sharing that and that news with us
you just mean you just boosting my
spirits yeah damn dude make me touch my
own chest and the cool thing about my
got a chest of a damn you know a [ __ ]
you know Falcon with [ __ ] heartburn
you know I got a I got a damn I got a
chest like a [ __ ] canary that's uh
you know been doing only chest and
always you know can't get there on leg
day but thank you for your call man
let's take another call here nine eight
five six six four nine five zero three
is the number oh yeah at a party with
Bobby Lee's so do Bobby got up took an L
son I don't even know if they have if
they can pronounce L in whatever Bobby
speaks but he [ __ ] took one and then
I got up and took her now baby
me and Bobby was the male takers we were
some L takers man god damn and you know
what is even more embarrassing than
going and having to show up at like some
rich people
party and perform and these people that
had some real acts they had to who last
year and they had Rae sremmurd they had
you know some real hitters and this year
they got us dog it was going so bad one
time you could hear that you wanted to
have one of them chocolate fountains and
that thing is just damn then I [ __ ]
made a wish in that [ __ ] I was like hot
damn bruh I waste a nickel on this [ __ ]
something will come true but but that
you could I could hear the chocolate
fountain go and that's how quiet it was
at one point but it was a beautiful time
there and they had a lot of beautiful
ladies and beautiful men up there and I
like to watch rich people eat because
rich people eat like they're gonna eat
again soon rich people might or might
not some rich people they put something
on their plate and they don't even
[ __ ] eat it please you just do you
just basically just store and [ __ ] at
that point hmmm let's get this hitter
right here here's a call that came in uh
homeward feel it straight from Portland
Oregon
what's up Trey thank you for hitting the
hotline I was sitting here listening to
your podcast from Christmas Eve and
there was a young lady who was so
excited about getting married and
graduating in college and it all sounds
well and good until the end she's
talking about moving out to Portland oh
yeah remember this call last week dad a
young lady and it was the best weekend
of her life within 10 days she graduated
college
she'd been like nursing student of the
year or something and then she had oh
she got proposed to sorry and then they
were moving to Portland yes Oh word
puddle town he found urine though this
place is the mecca of the dark arts
oh is it really in Portland
why spent time I've gone and seen
anything too bad really
now they do have a good strong hit of
urine in certain areas you know it's
very pissed centric over there somewhere
off at a downtown more and I have not
known a couple myself included that
hasn't moved out here and broken up
within four to five months of crossing
the state line but she sounds like a
sweet young lady and though Iowa and
pigtails and hog wrangling and all that
jazz don't come out here
there are bums and piss damn now he's
now that's the second time you've cited
piss brother and you might have an
infatuation with that strong yellow free
liquid and almost said beverage but it
is only a liquid
unless you're trapped in a avalanche I'm
if you ever been in an avalanche before
but suddenly urine is wine let's hear
more and strip clubs and the devil is
crawling out of the sewers looking for
people like you
damn okay so that man is uh not working
for he ain't working for you know that
dudes not a coyote that's gonna try to
smuggle you into Portland let's do does
not want people there and I'm betting
maybe he has something he don't want to
share with people that guy might have
something special he might have a secret
recipe or some gold bullion or something
and he sound like he might be a secret
type of person let's take some other
calls here and these were in response
last week we had a young man that called
up he was trying to relate to his
brother he had an older brother he was
trying to relate to him on some levels
and man it was nice as weekend to see my
brother and uh and there's just
something man what a gift if you have a
brother you know
[Music]
to have somebody else that have the same
blood in them as you that is I mean
there's some Frankenstein style shitake
Gang Gang let's hear it here we go hey
Greg from Philly he's called in about
his brother living far away and like 11
years apart he's in Texas he's in
Colorado and it's just tough to get
close and I thought I had something
maybe a little bit topical so yeah my
brother and I were like we look like
we're twins were real similar but I
don't know man like I have a lot of
trouble being close and I mean I really
wanted to get better with my brother so
I like moved in with him like I'm living
with a man right now okay so if you're
living with somebody then that's that's
a real move cuz that is y'all could be
damn husband but you're already brothers
so that'd be crazy and they had a boy
when I was growing up named Eric Slavoj
and everybody said that his brother was
his father and we didn't ever see any
you know pictures or anything but people
did sometime do drawings of you know his
mom doing some kind of wild [ __ ]
homework but it's so hard like there's
always difficulties with brothers I
don't know what it is like the genetic
similarity syncing up and repelling or
some crazy [ __ ] like Oh what they say
man two brothers don't make a right say
man is like tell your brother you love
them try to pick something he's
interested in like my brother loves
stand-up comedy you know gives me to
kill Logan's and two years later I'm
listening with Yvonne every Monday and
Thursday and we talked about comedy man
it might be our main or only
similarities but it's something dude
that's what got a look at it you've got
to try to find that one connection one
commonality Gang Gang Gang man I'm glad
you and your brother had that experience
I could sit there laughs chuckle listen
to things and do a little bit of comedy
trying to think what my brother or not
like and that is a good suggestion fine
one thing it could be small like a
belittle y'all might like you know throw
javelins are you know looking uh you
know looking for sinkholes or something
you know you guys might like doing
recipes or making a you know making fun
of magicians you might like you know you
might like gerbils you might like
baseball you might like little Christmas
trees and you know doing little um
origami with the wood you know and you
might like making candles together or
you know reading about electricity to
each other at night doing you know
bedtime stories or you know drawing maps
there's all types of things you could
enjoy but that is good a suggestion to
find a commonality let's take another
call that came in for the young man with
us some suggestions for him over oh do
what uh I'm calling about the gentleman
who was having trouble connecting with
his uh his brother of eleven years you
know one way that I've always thought is
a really a good way to get close to my
siblings one of them is 29 year there is
25 I am 21 myself so sometimes it's hard
to relate to them you know they they
live in different states but something I
always do is tell them things that I
would only tell my best friend like
secret ooh that's a good one because if
you tell a secret a secret is basically
just glue that's coming out of your
mouth a secret will attach you to
somebody you know a secret I mean you
put a secret in somebody you got to
[ __ ] know where they're at at all
times because they got you [ __ ] you know
what I'm saying let's hear more like
where I hid the peanut butter or
something like that you know so there's
still some deep dark secrets and that
usually helps you out so oh yeah
and I used to do [ __ ] like that man I
used to tell you know I remember telling
my
you know one of my siblings at one of my
other siblings was uh you know
homoerotic and they weren't but for like
a year they thought they were and so you
know that's a secret it's not a real
secret but it's still a secret
I remember going on we went camping when
I was young or we were hiding from
something I don't remember what it was
but I told everybody the second we left
to go camping I told everybody Jay Leno
had died in Jay Leno as a nighttime
comedian on television and I told
everybody that man that man died and the
truth was he didn't die but the whole
time we were camping people thought that
he was dead and so that's a secret so
the thing is you can just do a secret
but do it with your family that's it
tell him you've been [ __ ] eaten you
know little fish or something swallowing
minnows you know because they will eat
out though you know probiotics that's in
your colon or something do something
start some fun at the house but that's a
good idea
let's take another call that came in and
and I hope everybody did have a good
holidays you know I saw my whole family
except for you know I didn't get to see
one of my sisters and that makes me kind
of sad and my I didn't get to see my
mother my mother doesn't live in our
back in Louisiana anymore and I remember
how I didn't remember this I remember
when I was young um you know my mom
sometimes didn't have a lot of money to
get us something nice for Christmas you
know when she always would put out the
gifts and have a tree and and I remember
you know one time she got us some
two-liter sodas and I got that cherry
7up and she got us all each some
two-liter sodas and we would shake them
[ __ ] up in the yard and just
were spraying each other down with them
I'm really just enjoying you know that
was like our gift and we loved it you
know we loved having that just you know
the soda because you shake a soda up
that bitch's a gun that bitch's a strait
gun and we get that soda and just splash
that soda all over each other's bodies
and just you know lick it off each other
shoulders and [ __ ] and we was children
and we was enjoying the world and if you
never just chased another one of your
damn little why you know whiny little
spicy ass siblings around with a damn
shook up two liter and doused that [ __ ]
up and am i saying [ __ ] female I'm
talking about that little male [ __ ] and
doused that be up and then just been
giggling so [ __ ] hard you just you
know you got cherry 7up just flying out
of your nose and you just orange
crushing [ __ ] and doing just
you know Shaston you know anybody that
says got the same DNA as you and just
y'all just enjoying laughing and rolling
on the ground and just you know licinus
you know the the the soda will dry up on
your shoulders and you can lick it off
each other shoulders and it's a damn
treat and it is a damn treat and
sometimes you know even the smallest
gift like a two-liter can be just a damn
just gallons and gallons of sheer joy
you know I mean it can just be gallons
and gallons of sheer joy I'll say this
though man my mother one time you know
she didn't have something for us and she
did it she so she made up funnier she
made up a scavenger hunt and she sent us
on this and this thing was long as hell
man we had to go to the bus station we
had to we had a they had better get a
Pierrot from somebody and borrow it like
a you know somebody across town that she
knew and she set it up with these other
parents it was such a long scavenger
hunt it took us a probably you know it's
about a day and a half ordeal
until we could get to our gifts and she
had needed that extra day to work you
know that December 26 she needed that to
work to get the money and then then on
December 27th when we found it gave us
all the way back in our back porch right
there and they had bikes and they had
bikes for us and you know I didn't know
at the time that that's what she needed
she needed an extra day deck to get the
cash you know to do some work but you
know moms can do incredible things
around the holidays and it is a special
time and I hope that this holidays was
special for you let's take another call
here here we go speaking of moms hey CEO
it's Alex um I know you don't know who I
am
but the other day we met at the Comedy
Store and let you know about some things
that you've helped me throughout my life
and I was just listening to episode
number 22 about how you said it's never
too late to call your mom and I do
suffer from depression and relationship
issues because no more lost music here
oh man I'm sorry to hear some of that
stuff and uh and thank you for calling
and being you know just about your [ __ ]
because sometimes even though we have
you know these you know sometimes we
want to be construction paper and you
know and we're just confetti you know
but we're still a colorful group all
word and my went ahead and give her a
call just to tell her I love her
randomly and I'll see that again man
let's go through that to call your bomb
and I do suffer from depression and
relationship issues because no bomb left
me as a kid and my went ahead and give
her a call just to tell her I love her
randomly and when she started crying so
you know I just wanted to the holidays
get a little lonely for me you know it's
Christmas Eve tomorrow and I just wanted
to say thank you for being there for me
because all I got is in the dog you know
so I just wanted to tell you how much I
appreciate you and everything that he's
helping lift and thank you for inspiring
to call on Mommy's anomaly hold a grudge
and you know fell lonely at times
because I live alone you're welcome man
you know it's funny you say that kind of
stuff man and you know I don't feel like
I have anything to do you know you're
welcome and thank you for calling and
being a part of the podcast you know
it's hard for me sometimes man to call
my mother as well you know because
there's parts of me inside of me that
feel you you know I love my mother when
I hear her voice it makes me an extreme
uncomfort starts up inside of me and
it's and I have to just bear with that
and communicate with her and even been
to tell her you love her man
that's you know that that takes some you
know your Fergie R it takes some
forgiveness but man what a powerful
thing that is to forgive somebody to say
instead of making an issue about this
instead of you know you know just taking
a curling iron to the to the world right
now I'm gonna find some way that to look
past it and just tell you that I love
you because whatever things that our
parents did to us or made us feel
uncomfortable man I'm sure that they're
not happy about it I'm sure all they
really want is you know for us to love
them and for them and for us to allow
them to love us so when you're able to
just get through all of that and just
say man even though the last thing I
want to do right now probably in in 8
and 99% of my body is tell us person I
love them but that a [ __ ] rod that 1%
bro
yeah it's powerful it's a powerful thing
to do man so I appreciate you telling me
about this in remind me of it from
episode 22 and here we are in the
episode 160 and 161 and that's a
beautiful memory man because now I'm
gonna remember that next time I'm having
an issue with my mother you know next
time I don't want to hear her voice or I
don't want to you know be kind I'm gonna
think well maybe she needs me to be kind
maybe it's not about how I feel maybe
it's about how I could make someone else
feel if I'm able to look past myself
that's a new experience man that's
powerful stuff
let's take we'll get two more calls
right here and and thank you guys for
hitting the hotline nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three I'm a
little tired this week man it's been a
long time and you know and I've been you
know back on the cigarettes and I'd been
off them cigarettes you know it and what
had happened was I watched that movie a
star is born
damn man I thing had me [ __ ] dripping
out my face bra and I had nine days I
think of no smoking and I saw that movie
and I just man it hit me if you want to
I don't if you've ever taken a dishrag
and it's wrong the water out of it but
if you want a film to do that to your
dang tear ducts then a star is born as
the movie for you alright let's hit this
hitter right here let's get this hitter
uh let me uh let me get this hitter
right here homework hey what's up Co
it's uh Ryan here from Illinois and I'm
calling I got a I got an issue it's
about the fighter and the kid
guest of the year
yup and thank you for calling that guest
of the year I think the voting will
probably be over after today and and
that is for fighter and the kid
listeners to pick their a guess that
they most enjoyed on that amazing
podcast the fighter and the kid as well
the second episode of King and the sting
will be out later this week
onward you know obviously get the farms
with the brides holding onto that belt
right now but God knows what's going to
happen here all I'm saying is I've been
a fan of yours
and crystal is hmm and that's who it's
up apparently it's out of myself and
Chris dilly-o dilly-o don't doll and and
you know and I think anybody could win
it home Burt but I had to get a good
laugh when you commented about him in
the whole thing being rigged on that
post they made the fighting the kid once
I like those two comments you made Chris
D'Elia blocked me on Instagram
ain't that some [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't
know all I'm saying is the system may or
may not be rigged still hold on charge
it assigns with the bronze baby you're
coming in hot you want to enjoy the yeah
we'll see brother you know I think
everybody should have a chance to be a
champ and it could happen but I'll be
damned if I uh you know if I don't want
to keep growing it I don't want to keep
growing the excitement you know because
when they gave me that strap last year
that was like handing me just like a
little baby and that was like handing me
a little baby snicker man like that like
that beautiful fella that called up
earlier the snicker Cabbage Patch baby
boy and and and I do want this thing to
grow but we'll see we'll see what
happens I mean it's almost we'll know
soon but man I somebody said the next
belt is supposed to be nicer than the
one they got me
and knees bastard let me tell you about
this brand and Sam and they dumped what
the [ __ ] Donnie count
Bryan Callen the belt they got me one
hundred and sixty-two dollars
thing has fallen apart twice I'm on my
third belt okay I called him and I
complained to him after it happened the
first one fell off some piece of [ __ ]
fell almost got me in trouble at
security over there and um outside of
Charlotte
well these bastards said we should have
got the warranty on it [ __ ] you
give it to me as a prize I didn't know a
warranty option and don't give me a
piece of [ __ ] a piece of [ __ ] ain't a
prize boy okay unless I'm a manure man
and I'm not so well said let's let's get
into one more one more right here nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three I want to thank everybody that's
been uh that's been a part of this past
weekend everybody that came out to the
shows Louisiana you mean you did make me
feel I didn't know I was gonna be as
supportive as I was and it really did
feel nice and I promise I tried my
hardest and next year maybe you know you
know God willing we'll do it at a place
where there's more it's more of a
there's not as many bars you know
because the House of Blues had bars in
the room but man it was still great and
and look one thing I gotta realizes you
know if you do um if you do a show where
there's bars in the room didn't there's
gonna be people drinking and getting
boozed out you know it's like if you do
um if you try to juggle you know and
somebody's you know pouring lemon juice
in people's eyes
then you might [ __ ] up bro so you just
got to be aware of the circumstances
let's take this call here we go Merry
Christmas
thank you Sam thank you for the call
from Tennessee I have a question I'd
like to issue to your listeners who are
parents that have raised children into
young adulthood and into adulthood I'm
kind of struggling married and have a
biological son okay you got that bio
baby and that's old-fashioned a lot of
people now they got a stepchild or you
know just a local [ __ ] that they
buying snacks for but you got that real
deal
onward and step-daughter who is in a
first year high school the whole time
that I've known her she's she's real
sneaky she's real sneaky sneaky Sheila
and manipulative hmm I'm worried I
worried that she's not going to blossom
and take on the responsibilities of
being an adult very well or getting into
some kind of decision she'll Mike will
lead her into something that can't be
undone okay and you talking about
pregnancy they're usually usually you
took my pregnancy right there I'll say
this you know I was a sneaky child and I
was a manipulative child and I don't
know what an adult could have done that
would have adjusted me you know I think
especially if she's a stepchild she
probably developed those skills because
they were survival skills for her you
know she felt like she had to manipulate
the world all right in some way just
manipulate it changed the world in order
for her to feel comfortable in it so she
got used to being able to manipulate
things
you know in the end the best way man is
to just love her you know you know you
may not always have to you know
financially support things if you think
that she's trying to be secretive or or
snaky but but along the way some stuff
is gonna be out of your control man you
know if she gets knocked up by some guy
who's in a gang or something like that
or you know she get you know a couple
brothers or something like that or you
know some dude a white dude he can't
read or something you know all of those
people have semen in them and I'm not
saying anything wild could happen but if
she does something happened man she's
gonna need somebody still to love her
and that could be something you can do
you know you ain't got to give her all
extra bread you don't have to drop out
an extra $40 a week so she could you
know she's saying she's getting you know
a new skirt or something for the dance
and she's getting the UM you know one of
them mom marijuana vape pens or
something named hitters then [ __ ]
squirrely dope hitters so there's
options onward most recently we went
Christmas shopping and we gave her an
opportunity to prove herself responsible
young adult and possibly get a little
bit more freedom and responsibilities
all she had to do was watch your brother
not even 15 yet and couldn't make it the
whole day and it was a little [ __ ]
headed boy at my house had nothing
transpired my father is my neighbor so
he put an end of that but hell yeah
and it's okay if your father has a
[ __ ] weapon too bro you know I'll
tell you this dude I can't even imagine
catching a dude with your little
daughter bro I'll [ __ ] rearrange that
dude's knuckles though cuz you look some
guy coming over at a young age that
guy's thinking about crunch he's
thinking about that sea rocks you know
he's thinking about hiding that little
you know pink that red
rocket he's thinking about hiding that
red rocket
so to him if she's out there I mean yeah
cuz you don't want to end up with some
liabilities either you know you don't
want to end up with any liabilities so I
think yeah she had a little boy over how
do you mean some of the stuff she's just
gonna do it you know I think you just
have you got I don't know I don't have
any children
does anybody have any children they
might know something to suggest this man
has a sneaky stepdaughter dude Oh word
he just proven over the course of the
time that I've known her that if you
leave her alone
without any supervision she'll make some
bad decisions so this one here what your
listeners particularly parents and think
about that and I'll hang up and listen
okay gang gang man thank you for that
the child yes she needs everybody needs
to learn something and have an
opportunity you know this is a kid this
is a kid in there as a parent yeah I'm
sure it's a tough line because you have
to make sure that they're safe and okay
and at the same time let them grow and
that's got to be wild that's got to be
you know it's like having a weed you
know you want it to grow you know you
want to control it but it needs to do
its own thing or you want to control it
but it's gonna do its own thing or
[ __ ] maybe it's not even like a Weed
Man
I don't know what it's like but I don't
have any children and but I do wish you
could have a new experience with this
and maybe some insights from some of
these other parents are could help you
have just that so if you have it a
couple of suggestions for this man if
you've had a similar environment you can
hit the hotline nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three I
I just want to say happy new year and I
hope that that we get into some good
stuff this year I think we'll have an
episode next week might do a best of the
year something I'm not sure but we'll
definitely there will be a king in the
sting episode part of me still maybe
needs a little bit of a break a little
bit of rest I've been trying to get more
rest and trying to stay active too you
know just trying to get more on top of
um you know taking care of my mind and
my body and my spirit oh you know cuz I
wanna I want to experience I want to
have a new experience you know I want to
have a new experience I want to be able
to you know I want to be able to be you
know all I can be and feel all I can
feel and and be present for not only the
possibilities but just the moments that
occur in my life you know I guess I
don't know I don't know but I do want to
thank you for being with us this year
happy new year to you and to yours and
and be good to yourself and you you
probably deserve it
[Music]
this is a new beginning by Peter
Sandberg onward
[Music]
you